three hundred thousand tons of steel a
day
1,000 cars an hour food for 100 million
people half the largest cities in
America trade center of the nation more
universities more freshwater ways more
industry more agriculture than any other
region in the world this is the Midwest
heartland of the nation
from the Mesabi Range in Minnesota to
the cold fields of Kentucky from the
steel mills of Pittsburgh to the wheat
fields of Nebraska these of a long
horizons of the Midwest most of the
world's population and wealth is found
in regions near the sea why is America's
Midwest
an exception to this general rule to
examine the wealth of this region we
must first look at its land thousands of
years ago it was leveled by glacial ice
the vegetation which followed the ice
left most of the land with a rich soil
ideal for agriculture
now the Midwest has a rich dairy belt in
the north to supply milk for the cities
of the region and cheese and butter for
export to other regions the southern
portion of the heartland is well-suited
to general farming but across the middle
of the region lies the most important
agricultural area in the nation the Corn
Belt and it is here in the Midwestern
Corn Belt that our story begins with a
man who has seen remarkable changes over
the last half century when I came here
50 years ago 60 bushels to the acre was
considered a high yield today in
comparison 180 bushes is a high yield
mr. Charles Gunn an Midwestern scientist
who has devoted his life to improving
the corn plant 85% of the corn grown
approximately is fed to livestock the
Midwest handles more beef and more hogs
than any other region in the nation this
morning John Piggott a progressive
Illinois farmer he's shipping some of
his animals to mark
good highways and the modern truck have
changed the farmers method of getting
products to market this slaughterhouse
40 miles from the farm is the
destination of mr. Pickett's beef when
John was a young boy almost all beef was
sent by rail to the large packing houses
of Chicago
now the packing houses have moved out of
the city we still just been out here
about four years now and it is a
convenience just ship over here
we still have to sell we can get the
best price we'll sell the Swift
we'll sell an Armour which is over here
at Sterling which is 60 miles away which
is about the same distance of Chicago
but we just have to sell the demand at
all that'll give us the most money for
the cattle that's about the only way we
determine who we're gonna sell to
Midwest farmers are so productive that
overproduction and the tougher market
competition have become serious problems
our big problem is that we don't really
have much bargaining power when we go
buy our cattle we have to buy them at
the price that the man wants to sell on
that if we can buy them a little cheaper
we try to but basically speaking we have
we give his price and when we turn
around to sell our product we take the
price again that they'll give us and
we're one of the few people that do this
we don't have enough bargaining power
we're going to have to organize as
producers and get in a bargaining
position with these chain stores and the
people that are gonna consume our meat
today the market was good but next month
prices may drop this is the problem
facing every farmer in America every
time he buys for the future we usually
buy in the south southwest majority I
cannot come from Texas my father and I
or either maybe just one of us will go
down there at least once a year and look
at these cattle and usually buying them
we may not buy them the day we see him
we not may not buy him till two or three
months later over the phone hello John
Piggott a decal oh yeah
just fine say we're looking for some
campers weighing approximately five six
hundred pounds you have those heifers
that you spoke about earlier uh-huh
those are Hereford heifers
what what's the price you're asking for
those cattle now that's a little bit
higher than we want to pay our market
isn't that good
well we better buy him around twenty
four and a half cents at the highest
laid into us here at home that's right
well we'll we'll bid you twenty four and
a half cents a pound on those Hereford
heifers if you want to deliver them to
the cow when one could we get those
cattle side 180 to 200 days that they'll
double their money which of course isn't
all profit about 75% of that doubling
money we're talking about will be feed
cost we would consider this a fair
return
the midwest has become the meat
tenderizer to the nation because of the
corn that it feeds the livestock
mr. Pickett's farm produces two and
one-half times as much as it did 30
years ago
for the equipment necessary for this
increased production in 1903 John
Pickett's grandfather and Irish
immigrants began a dairy operation on
this land the farm has remained in the
family through two world wars and a
Great Depression again there are new
faces on the farm my father's been in
the cattle business a good number of
years and I always did enjoy wanted to
be in it and as far as raising a family
there's just no place to raise a family
like in the country and it's a good life
there's no question about it
John's brothers have not gone on to
farming and throughout the Midwest and
the nation the farm population is just
half what it was a generation ago when
these children grow up they will face an
unusual situation constantly rising
productivity in the face of serious farm
problems
poor marketing methods high cost of
machines and labor rising land values
and taxes these are the problems which
face the children of the world's most
productive land but farming is only half
the story of the Midwest for the land
which provided the agricultural
opportunities also gave us the
beginnings of a great industrial boom in
1837 and Midwestern er John Deere began
to develop steel plows to work the
Midwestern soil a few years later Cyrus
McCormick began making reapers in
Chicago to be near his farm customers
now almost every need of the consumer is
provided by Midwestern industry the rich
topsoil may have attracted the farmer
but in the lower layers of earth
industry found the energy to run its
machines energy in the form of coal
[Music]
now almost half the nation's energy
comes from the Midwest in cadiz Ohio a
large-scale strip mining operation
provides coal to energy users in the
heartland and neighboring regions the
potential power from the earth had to be
matched by an energetic people
I am Craig Robert I have been working
for the company approximately 26 years I
started as a ditch digger run tractor
and oiled and finally worked myself into
the position I am in now
[Music]
machine is operated by two hand controls
and two foot controls this is a hundred
and five cubic yards which would be
equal to two railroad cars of material
[Music]
half the coal has been exposed a small 9
cubic yard machine will come in and take
the coal and load it in two hundred and
twenty ten trucks and the trucks will
transport it approximate two miles to
our cleaning plant to be worse size and
dry and put on the railroad car to the
customer
most of our shipping goes north
michigan's our biggest customer
[Music]
from southeastern Ohio the coal is sent
across the states into Indiana and up to
Michigan what industry needs materials
to work and the energy resources of the
Midwest are matched by large mineral
deposits just below the surface of the
earth in Minnesota lies the country's
most important deposit of iron ore
because of its ease of mining and
nearness to the Great Lakes the Mesabi
Range has been important to the success
story of industry in the Midwest or is
easily shipped to steel mills on the
Great Lakes which supply steel to the
nation from Indiana Illinois Ohio
Pennsylvania and Michigan
here in Detroit raw ore arrives at a
typical steel mill the Great Lakes
freeze up during the winter and are only
safe for navigation seven or eight
months out of the year therefore during
the shipping season large quantities of
ore our stockpile at the steel mill to
feed the furnaces that will operate
every day of the year
[Music]
steal for refrigerators and toasters
steal for lawn mowers and flowers steal
for safety pins and nails steel to be
sent out all over the nation and the
world but the most important single
steel user in the Midwest as well as the
nation is the auto industry the physical
birth of every car is here in the
infernal Heat of the blasters
one out of every five pounds of steel
made in America goes into an automobile
and the pattern of producing automobiles
is typical of much Midwest industries
[Music]
[Applause]
from the mill in Michigan rolls of Steel
are sent south to the town of Twinsburg
Ohio only a few trucking hours away by
modern roads here the metal for our car
begins to take a more familiar shape
the drug has a force of a thousand ton
on the punch in approximately 700 done
on the outer ring which holds the blank
it running rate is approximately 430 an
hour I've been here at about 10 and a
half years
by trade on the tool and die maker I've
been working with automation for quite a
few years
they're shipped throughout the country
anywhere from Delaware to Los
Detroit st. Louis del retiro Illinois
although auto assembly plants have been
built throughout the country in recent
years most are located within the
Midwest and Detroit is still uncontested
as the auto capital of the world and it
is here that our car will be assembled
from parts manufactured throughout the
Midwest parts like the engine carved out
of cast-iron in Trenton Michigan on
machines made in the Midwest
[Music]
in Jackson Michigan the tires are
vulcanized out of materials shipped in
the Midwest from all over the world
while the heavy products of a car are
produced near the factory the more
delicate and expensive instruments can
be made wherever labor is available so
it is the Delavan a small town in
southern Wisconsin
we'll make the clock for our car
[Music]
[Applause]
the Midwest has hundreds of light
industry towns that subcontract for the
large manufacturing centers of the
heartland and the nation and so our car
is shipped in pieces to the assembly
plant in Detroit some 15,000 parts in
all are needed for a typical American
automobile probably wondering what these
computers have to do with building cars
well when you go to your dealer and
order a car with particular equipment
like white walls a clock and a radio and
a heater that order is punched into
cards that look like this we receive
these cards and run them through this
machine this tells the people out in the
plant behind me here what to put on the
car and when to put it on
our car will be assembled in less than
half a day this plant turns out a car
every 60 seconds
[Music]
the technology that built the car has
brought us wealth and fantastic urban
expansion but sometimes centralization
conflicts with the prosperity we've
earned now more than a quarter of the
nation's population lives in the Midwest
most of the population growth has taken
place in the cities because of the
advantages afforded by urban living its
wealth of goods and services
[Music]
it's cultural opportunities it's trade
centers like this one in Chicago where
the law requires voice bidding on farm
commodities
[Applause]
the wealth of the city allows it to
support excellence in spectator sports
[Applause]
but the concentration of people
compounds the problems of human
engineering
[Music]
and do mr. Jones in reply to your letter
of the 14th I would like to say that our
board of directors
dear mr. Johnson we were very happy to
see her
concerning rates for regularly-scheduled
with the enormous wealth that
industrialization has brought us we have
inherited the monumental problems of
poverty
[Music]
these are the problems only people can
solve people like the farmer coal miner
machinist the painter the engine builder
the auto assembler the office workers
these are the people who face the
challenges of the Midwest